Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández hoy
los llevaremos a España
la vivienda digna para todos es uno de
los Derechos reflejados en la
Constitución española sin embargo cada
año se llevan a cabo decenas de miles de
desalojos o expulsiones solo en los seis
primeros meses de 2022 la cifra llegó a
22.000 desde 2003 superan el medio
millón debido a la inflación muchas
familias invierten la mayoría de su
sueldo en alojamiento desde el estallido
de la burbuja Inmobiliaria en 2008 en
España cientos de personas perdieron sus
casas o locales que fueron hipotecadas
ahora muchos de estos inmuebles
permanecen vacíos desde hace años
varias organizaciones han decidido
utilizar esos espacios deshabitados para
vivir o para desarrollar actividades
sociales que beneficien al vecindario
Marina Colorado y William González nos
traen un reportaje sobre el fenómeno de
la ocupación de viviendas y locales en
España me acompaña Marina Colorado
bienvenida Marina comienzo preguntándole
qué hay detrás de este fenómeno de la
ocupación de las viviendas vacías Y qué
está haciendo el gobierno de España al
respecto
pues es una reacción al abuso que como
bien mencionabas herminia ha hecho la
banca desde el 2008 Desde esa crisis
económica e Inmobiliaria en el país y
también una reacción a un aumento muy
pronunciado de los precios del alquiler
en España y de las hipotecas que ha
hecho que la mayoría de las personas
tenga que gastar un 40% de su sueldo en
vivienda un porcentaje muy alejado del
recomendado de 30% y un porcentaje que
en Madrid y Barcelona las dos ciudades
donde grabamos este reportaje Iguala o
supera el
50%, por eso para paliar algunas de
estas problemáticas y para bajar los
precios de la vivienda imponer más a
disposición del público es que el
gobierno quiere promover o está
promoviendo una ley de vivienda a nivel
Estatal pero que lleva meses estancada
en su proceso legislativo Aunque el
gobierno Espera que sea aprobada en las
primeras semanas de este año 2023
Gracias Marina ya regresamos con usted
aquí la historia
[Música]
Quién viene por primera vez bienvenidas
no estáis sola una vez que paséis por la
tarde y como cada semana desde 2009 se
reúne la plataforma de afectadas por la
hipoteca de Barcelona un movimiento
social que defiende el derecho a la
vivienda digna y promueve cambios
legislativos para que la vivienda en
España deje de ser un bien de Mercado
fue creada a raíz de la crisis económica
de 2008 y del aumento de las cuotas
hipotecarias que hizo que mucha gente no
pudiera seguir pagando y perdiera sus
casas esa ley no está sigue vigente no
hoy en día también Vale pues es verdad
que nos pueden quitar la casa y
dejarnos una deuda de por vida
15 años después del estallido de la
crisis el problema con la vivienda sigue
muy actual Aunque el perfil de personas
que acuden a estas asambleas ha cambiado
Es verdad que Nacimos en 2009 con el
problema hipote pero aquí en Barcelona
ya desde el 2012 básicamente vienen
sobre todo familias o personas que
tienen problemas con pagos de alquiler
finalizaciones de contrato sobre todo
también personas que están ocupando que
Aún estando trabajando no pueden Acceder
al mercado libre no el mercado de
alquiler y han tenido que ocupar porque
era ocupar un piso vacío de la banca o
bien pues vivir en la calle literalmente
una situación que desde hace años vive
Sonia que tras haber tenido que entregar
su casa al banco y quedarse con una
deuda de 8.000 euros ahora intenta que
le renueven el alquiler social que
tenían Y entonces lo único que yo pido
como pedimos muchísimas familias que nos
sentimos de esta manera tan maltratada
tan utilizadas en ser números antes que
personas lo único que pedimos que se nos
aplique la ley es lo único que pedimos
en febrero de 2022 la plataforma de
afectadas por la hipoteca logró que en
Cataluña se aprobara una ley por la que
las empresas bancos o fondos de
inversión con más de 10 inmuebles Bajo
su propiedad estén obligados a ofrecer
alquiler social de sus viviendas vacías
[Aplausos]
aún así el camino no es fácil
[Música]
Carmen y Antonio llevan más de dos años
tratando de conseguir un alquiler que se
ajusta sus posibilidades pero no ha
habido suerte todavía eso debido a
preguntar qué hago en 2019 les echaron
de su casa por no poder seguir pagando
el arriendo tras un año viviendo con sus
padres en 2020 decidieron ocupar este
apartamento en manos de un fondo de
inversión que ha ignorado sus peticiones
de alquiler social
este de
2000 de 2020 que ahí cuando empecemos
con Inés ahora se tiramos con seis meses
llevándolo una gestora y a los seis a
los seis meses pasan a otro estamos
hablando diciendo no lo llevo yo ya
ahora lo llevo a esta chica o este chico
se van pasando la pelota
desde que empezó hasta el día de hoy la
ley catalana les obliga a otorgar la
vivienda para el alquiler social Pero
esta pareja de 39 y 41 años no ha
recibido más que silencio o respuestas
que alargan el proceso durante meses
porque es un sin vivir sabe que vas a
estar pero no sabe hasta cuándo
no vives no te deja vivir si en que vaya
haciendo una cosa a otra pero sí que
tu cabeza se room cuando cuando cuando
cuando cuando cuando
cuando vendrá El desahucio cuando no
es una agonía
le mandemos la documentación y todo y
ellos no nos han contestado una agonía
que agrava los problemas de salud de
Antonio que a raíz de la inestabilidad
laboral y de vivienda que sufren desde
2019 fue diagnosticado con esquizofrenia
los nervios el no poder hacer nada
querer hacer y no poder ella te pide
hacer la presentas y luego nos ha
presentado que la puedas representar
y se ha perdido todos son
contra contra juntas no hay nada a tu
favor es una lucha muy fuerte esto
por ahora Carmen y Antonio están
protegidos por la suspensión de los
desahucios y lanzamientos aprobada por
el gobierno Estatal hasta mediados de
2023 una vez termine este plazo no saben
qué sucederá
según los últimos datos oficiales
disponibles en España y alrededor de 3,4
millones de viviendas vacías es decir
viviendas disponibles para su venta
alquiler o abandonadas
mientras que la mayoría de estas son de
particulares casi un 10% está en manos
de bancos y fondos de inversión que se
quedaron con miles de casas embargadas
desde la crisis inmobiliaria
[Música]
unas 50.000 las gestionan las haré
apodada a la bancamala una sociedad
encargada de vender estos activos
tóxicos para recuperar los 50.000
millones de euros de deuda pública
surgida de rescatar a las cajas de
ahorro en 2012 Pese a que las áreas de
mayoría pública desde abril de 2022 solo
unos 15.000 inmuebles están dedicados al
alquiler social Es verdad que hay muchas
familias que están en una situación muy
complicada que están ocupando una
vivienda sin título o que están en
procesos de lanzamiento de alquiler y
que todavía no tenemos ese encaje es
suficiente lo que se está haciendo hoy
por hoy no hace falta más y yo creo que
lo que estamos haciendo de cesárea es
una buena muestra
de pues de esa de esa política de
incrementar el parque Público
de vivienda en este caso para nuestros
clientes vulnerables pero no deja de ser
familias que viven en aquella esquina de
allí no y que esto está aportando mayor
oferta que es lo que hace falta
la vivienda en España es competencia de
cada región precisamente para regularla
a nivel Estatal y entre otras cosas
aumentar la cantidad de inmuebles
dedicados a fines sociales en el país el
gobierno aprobó en febrero de 2022 un
proyecto de ley que sigue en trámite
legislativo la Constitución española
afirma que los ciudadanos tienen derecho
a una vivienda digna y adecuada y que la
administración Pública regulará para
impedir la especulación
expertos en derecho a la vivienda niegan
que se esté haciendo porque el derecho a
la vivienda en este país no se concibe
como un Derecho sino que se concibe como
un bien de Mercado además sobre el que
se ha hecho mucho Bueno se ha basado
todo un pelotazo urbanístico todo el
motor económico de varias décadas de
hecho España es el país europeo con más
condenas del comité de derechos
económicos sociales y culturales de
Naciones Unidas por haber vulnerado el
derecho a la vivienda
para cumplir con los tratados
internacionales en esta materia la nueva
ley de vivienda la primera que se
aprobaría a nivel Estatal tendría que
incluir más protecciones habría otras
necesidades de intervención como sería
los procedimientos judiciales cuando hay
un desahucio no puede proceder proceder
en la ejecución del desahucio si no hay
una intervención de servicios sociales
o un pronunciamiento de servicios
sociales para dar una alternativa
habitacional eso que sí quise empezó a
nombrar en la ley a partir de 2019 no
queda claro y todavía sigue siendo
interpretable por los jueces eso se
tiene que optar por la ley
la falta de vivienda social en el país
la confirman las cifras mientras que la
media en Europa es de 9,3 viviendas
sociales por cada 100 existentes en
España no alcanza ni el 2% y la que hay
a veces no es utilizada o asignada de la
mejor manera se mantenga así lo vive
Katia Álvarez que desde hace 15 años
reside en un apartamento de alquiler
social propiedad de la comunidad de
Madrid un edificio plagado de problemas
de convivencia los ocupas como tal son
incluso familiares de los propios
adjudicatarios que sí tienen derecho a
la vivienda pero que han accedido a otra
vivienda Pues a la patada con una radial
abriendo esa vivienda que está vacía
porque nadie la pone en uso porque no se
adjudica esa vivienda familias que están
a la espera a través de un sorteo por
especial necesidad están a la espera de
esa vivienda Entonces qué hacen al verla
vacía pues se hacen con ella que a
partir de ahí Incluso hacen negocio con
ello alquilando habitaciones alquilando
la propia vivienda adquiriendo un
beneficio para ellos cuando esa vivienda
no es de ellos
ninguna de las denuncias y quejas que
apuesta ante la administración pública
ha tenido respuesta ni resultado es
necesario que hagan algo O sea ya el
resto que tienen que hacer ellos que es
administrar nuestros impuestos porque al
final todo esto lo pagamos todos que lo
gestionen de la mejor manera porque al
final es En beneficio o perjuicio de
todos las personas que están ocupando
una propiedad que no es suya
eventualmente son desalojadas la ley es
Clara en España sin embargo la justicia
es lenta esa lentitud en los procesos ha
hecho que proliferen compañías privadas
que se dedican a sacar a los ocupas de
las viviendas o locales
una de ellas la lidera Jorge que es
consciente de que ellos solo aceleran un
proceso que por la vía pública puede
demorarse hasta dos años
para hacer un bien moral Yo sé que hay
gente que intenta vender que somos los
salvadores del planeta pero eso es una
solución política
es una solución política nosotros
solucionamos problemas particulares
O sea no podemos solucionar la ocupación
porque no está en nuestras manos
mientras que la ocupación de viviendas
en España es bastante reciente la
ocupación como movimiento de
reivindicación social existe desde la
década de los 80 en el país su mayor
exponente son los centros sociales
ocupados es un espacio abandonado por
las haré que son los propietarios Bueno
legítimos aunque no queremos en su en
sus leyes y en su legitimidad Pero bueno
son los propietarios de este espacio y
nada eso desde hace un año le hemos dado
esa segunda vida este local llevaba al
menos siete años vacío ahora en él se
desarrollan varios proyectos para el
barrio todo esto era lo que eran
oficinas de hecho todavía mantenemos ahí
en la luz los nombres de las
trabajadoras del espacio
un gimnasio gratuito una biblioteca y
espacios para dar charlas una
alternativa de ocio que la
administración pública no ofrecía a los
jóvenes de la zona
según los militantes de la animosa Este
es un espacio liberado entre el
liberario creo que no hay mucha
diferencia
a lo mejor utilizamos liberar porque
creemos que este espacio hasta que
nosotros y nosotros entramos estaba
bueno capturado estaba cerrado esto
cuando nosotros entramos era un
conglomerado de instalaciones eléctricas
en un estado deplorable suciedad
entonces con este pequeño gesto nosotros
y nosotras creo que les hemos dicho que
basta Basta ya de que juegan con nuestro
dinero con nuestros espacios con
nuestros entornos
al final tanto Carmen y Antonio que
ocuparon un piso de la banca para tener
un techo como Álvaro y sus colegas que
utilizan un espacio que no es legalmente
suyo buscan con su lucha que el sistema
en España sea más justo para toda la
sociedad
estamos de vuelta con Marina Colorado
desde Madrid España marina Qué hay de
cierto en que las problemáticas que
rodean a la vivienda no son solo
económicas sino que se derivan en
problemas de salud física y mental
pues totalmente cierto Y es que se está
jugando con uno de los elementos más
básicos para que el ser humano pueda
tener una vida sana plena y poder
prosperar que es tener un techo donde
cobijarse tener un hogar de hecho todas
las personas con las que hablamos
durante la grabación de este reportaje
presentaban secuelas físicas o
emocionales que van desde abortos
sufridos por el estrés de no tener una
casa hasta el caso que vimos de Antonio
diagnosticado con esquizofrenia por
tener una paranoia constante y una
incertidumbre constante de no saber si
van a tener un techo en el que dormir al
día siguiente en cualquier momento se lo
pueden quitar hemos visto durante estos
días de grabación que falta mucho para
que el derecho a una vivienda digna en
España algo que está incluido en la
declaración universal de derechos
humanos y en la propia Constitución
española sea una realidad en este país
gracias a Marina Colorado hasta aquí
reporteros de la semana recuerde que
para sintonizar esta y las emisiones
anteriores puede visitar nuestro sitio
web France 24.com hasta la próxima
[Música]